when do you think you got enough you
don't have enough there's no don't know
enough
i don't have enough because it's not
over it's not over it's not over
that's what changed the entire destiny
of my family wow was that my grandma 30
with no college education
working at gimbal's department store
milwaukee wisconsin
got tired of being poor
anybody watching go look at any money
book look at chapter one you know what
they tell you to do in chapter one of
any book
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something greater inside you too
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life
and learn the five money habits behind
every rich person
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one obtain knowledge with kevin hart
i know you're rich as [ __ ] like when
when do you think you got enough you
don't have enough there's nobody
enough i don't have enough because it's
not over
it's not over it's not over so you know
when when you put a cap on it
you're putting a punctuation to it and
the the the ambition comes
from seeing what's out there that can be
obtained
you know when you see what's out there
like what can you mean physical things
like when you see what's out there when
you see
where people are really gaining
wealth and knowledge from okay the
business relationships that you're able
to acquire
the people that you're able to
partner with and create certain things
different revenue streams what i found
is
as a young black guy from north
philadelphia
the biggest problem with
the biggest problem within our community
his knowledge
we don't know debt debt is welcomed
because it's celebrated that's all we
know hey nah i'm get that credit card
i'm gonna
get that credit card up and it is what
it is they got to figure that out i
ain't got it after that
yeah well you know what i'm getting
student loans they gave it to me then
after that
there's what it is i'm figured out i put
a cable bill your name you put it in
my name we can switch it up whatever
they do it then let's just put it in
somebody else's name
it's welcome the hustle is welcome
the knowledge of banks and what you can
do or can't do
is is you don't even get it because you
go to check cash in places
the reason why you go to check cash
please because i don't want to go
through that bank don't trust that
go right there to check cash please let
me get mine let me get mine now take 30
whatever let me get it the knowledge
isn't given
so it's not till you obtain that
knowledge and understanding
that you go oh [ __ ] oh this is why you
put money up oh
this is this is how you increase versus
decrease
oh this is how you earn on your money oh
wow
i can gain wealth by investing in what
the stock world
is what how many people partake in the
stock world
and is there a part that isn't
necessarily gambling is there a low risk
part
these that's not the information isn't
there right so it's not so i got to a
certain level
and a certain group of people where i
got it and now that i got it
i want to give it so now i'm going to
give it
i'm going to give it to the people that
i don't need it most
and for me that younger generation of
black people
that don't understand the cool thing is
in
financial longevity not in the now
it's not in the moment for jewelry not
in the moment for the car
it's in the longevity it's in buildings
so at the end of the day you can say
look at what i have
look at what i worked for look at what i
have that's mine
monopoly is real but you have to have
the financial understanding
as you get older you learn this you
learn it
and and you know it's such a thing when
you talk about um
black versus white you know a lot of
people do that and
and rightfully so like there is racism
racism exists
i'm not unaware of that but there is a
high volume of it that's
that's non-existent to people that are
good people and when you can
merge yourself with good people and
follow
the paths that you see that these good
successful people
have taken you then become a part of a
world and group that nobody expected you
to be in
so for me i now have the position to do
that and take all of these relationships
and all this knowledge
and take it back to the people that need
it most i like to share i don't want it
all by myself
rule number two take control of your
money with ramit safety
so we grow up with these things i call
invisible scripts and these are the
scripts that are
beliefs that are so powerful we don't
even realize that
they're they're around us that's why
they're invisible so a classic one in
america
is the american dream is
buying a house where did that come from
and in fact there's all these phrases
that people use like
you're throwing money away on rent they
don't make more land you know and on
and on if you really deconstruct that
and you actually run the numbers you
might discover that
actually buying a house is often not the
best investment
and this is super counter-intuitive
people get really mad because real
estate is religion in america
but if you actually dive in deep you
might discover
wow there's a lot of parties who want me
to spend a ton of money that's why for
example
i could buy today but i rent and when
people hear that they're like
wait i thought i will teach you to be
rich guys
rich so why is he renting they get very
confused because real estate is religion
you know another thing that is um really
common
today for people is there's no way to
get ahead right especially for young
people
social security won't be around et
cetera et cetera
and i just don't believe in that i think
if you go on to reddit or you go on to
these places where
it's a it's a lot of people who are um
disaffected young people they create an
echo chamber
of other people who want to victimize
themselves
then you have a choice do you want to be
reading those threads
or like i was reading the comments on
your youtube videos i was like
these are the best youtube comments i've
ever seen people are positive
constructive they're pointing out things
they saw in the 32nd
minute of the video meaning they
actually watch the whole thing those are
the kind of people that i want people to
be around
so it's not impossible to make money
there's actually a lot of people making
money
it's not impossible to get ahead pay off
debt even invest and grow
there's a lot of people doing it but if
you're surrounded by people who
constantly complain about how difficult
it is and it's impossible
guess what you're going to absorb those
invisible scripts i had a woman who
wrote me and she said
ramit can you help me convince my
husband not to waste money
and i go okay what what's going on she
goes he spends
so much money on iced tea and i was like
here we go i go how much money and she
goes he buys iced tea
20 times a month like almost every day i
said how much is this iced tea
she said it's a dollar fifty each time
so in my head i'm like this is insane
like why are we even talking about this
but i knew there's something here so i
want to unpack it i said out of
curiosity what's your household income
no response for 20 minutes okay and then
finally she comes back she goes
i'm not comfortable sharing that i said
just give me a range
okay what do you think her her and her
husband's household income is
i know the story i i would have guessed
otherwise
80 000 like a nice
600 000 and the this is a perfect
example
like rationally and logically we should
literally not be talking about this
because it's a rounding error
but there's something going on in her
belief system
that made her fixate on iced tea
and so for anybody whether it's iced tea
or whether it's you know lattes is a
classic example everybody tells you not
to spend money i'm like that's the worst
advice ever buy as many lattes as you
want
or some people they just love for
example clothes
right i like clothes they love it but
everybody around them has told them
things like that's shallow that's a
waste of money
you should invest in your roth ira and
so what do they do all of us we're torn
apart
because we live in a paradoxical society
that is both
puritanical telling us we should retreat
into a cave and do nothing
but then we go on instagram and
everyone's in bora bora where it's
ridiculous
and so what do we do we just buy
everything and then we feel guilty
it's the worst possible response so what
i do is first i say
what do you love spending money on love
and nobody talks about this
they always say oh let me see your
budget you're overspending and
everyone's just like ah
forget this i'll never come on here and
berate someone for their spending
because
i've seen it all when they talk about
what they love then i say what would it
feel like to be able to spend
two times or four times as much on that
people have
never thought like that then once we
start from a place of aspiration of what
do we want
let's work through the mechanics of how
to get there really fast define a rich
life for people because i think that's
going to be a key component to this
whole discussion well it's different for
everyone
my rich life early on was to be able to
go to a restaurant and order appetizers
because i never did it when i was a kid
like ever we would go and
we'd eat out once every four to six
weeks if we had a coupon
and we would like share two cokes with
the whole family and we would
never order appetizers so i was like i'm
gonna do it
and then the next dream for me was to be
able to
hop in a taxi if i lived in new york
during the summer without having to take
the train and sweat
before a meeting now my dreams got
bigger and
there's a variety of things that are my
rich life but everybody's is different
so some people i have people in my book
they're like i use your book my wife and
i retired at 35 and 36 we drive around
in an rv
i don't want to drive around in an rv
but he and his wife do and i love that
so a rich life is what you define and
when i ask people what's a rich life to
you they usually say two things
freedom which is a very nice word but
it's kind of generic
and they say a number usually a million
bucks and i say like freedom what is
what is that to you and they're like i
want to do whatever i want when i want
and i'm like get specific you want to
order appetizers do you want to do yoga
at 3 p.m and that's where the
conversation stops
so if you're watching i want everyone to
think what is your rich life and take it
from the clouds to the street
i want to buy three different lululemon
tank tops a month
because i don't ever want to have to
wear an old one whatever
go as crazy as you want i want to travel
for a month and i want to bring my
family with me great a rich life is
different for everyone but is about
your definition most of what you see
with money
is just this mathematical logical stuff
and it sounds good and everyone's like
oh yeah compound interest
but then they go back to their
day-to-day life which is like i want
that sweater
i know i should be doing this how come
i'm not doing that i feel bad
close the book forget it and i want to
take a really different approach
a perfect example is if you look at any
money book
anybody watching go look at any money
book look at chapter one you know what
they tell you to do in chapter one of
any book
fine let's find out how much you spent
last month and people are like
no thanks see you later they don't know
how much they spent but they know it was
bad
and so if you actually understand human
psychology
you know that my goal is not to make you
feel bad my goal is actually to show you
how money can be
positive how you can live a rich life
whatever you want so in chapter one of
my book i said look we all use credit
cards we all suck at using credit cards
and we all hate credit cards
let me show you how to beat them read
these words off the page this
battle tested script and you'll get your
fees refunded and you'll get all these
perks you don't even know about
people did they're like i don't know
this indian guy is kind of weird i'll
try it
they pick up the phone even millennials
who are afraid of using the phone they
picked up the phone
they did it and they're like oh [ __ ]
they're talking they call the bank they
call them
yes and like that they get a 35
fee refunded or they get some perk they
never even knew existed
and suddenly psychologically they go oh
my god
i can take control of my money it's not
all these huge concepts of
retirement inheritance and all this
stuff no
i called i got money back
now i can do it so it's so important to
be
to be really incorporating your own
psychology when you think about money
and part of that is what do i want where
did i get these beliefs from
whether it's a movie or a family friend
and then what can i do today
to start moving along and developing my
rich life
also if you want to have confidence and
motivation check out my 254 series
they're free
the links to join are in the description
below everybody
successful lays the blueprint out you
laid the blueprint out
i wanted to be really successful but not
just to like get
shoes i knew i wanted to make money
because i wanted to make a difference
the difference for me though is i look
at failure as a stepping stone to
success
it's a speed bump i know i'm going to
fail
but it's not failure if you learn
something rule number three
never say no to honest money with marie
forleo
never say no to honest money so here's
what i mean by that
the other day i was walking home from a
video shoot right here in new york city
and i have to say i was pretty fried i
was like toast my head was down i had
this
huge bag on my shoulder and i'm walking
and i noticed a penny
now it didn't register at first and i
walked a few steps more and then i said
whoa wait that was a penny back there so
i turned around and i went back and i
picked it up
now i have to be honest part of me feels
like i should be
embarrassed or you know i'm picking up
money off the street is not pathetic
but then thank goodness the wiser part
of me said
screw that that's money i'm gonna pick
it up
that's because i have a little pact with
myself i
never say no to honest money and that
includes
honest abe i see you girl you're trying
to pick me up
i like it i am not too good
to pick up a penny or a nickel or a dime
or whatever off the ground
and whenever i notice money just laying
there i pick it up and i say
thank you this is awesome for me
it's a reminder that the universe is
always there to give me
whatever i need and all it takes for me
is to be
present to keep my eyes open and not be
too good for the little things for you
know the small blessings
i think there's also something really
humbling about
honoring that loose change because you
know about
a billion people in this world live on
less than
a dollar 25 a day so to just walk
past money no matter what the amount
seems incredibly arrogant and
disrespectful
so you may want to try this one out for
yourself
never say no to honest money if you see
loose change
scoop it up and say thank you rule
number four
aim to become an owner with david bach
on the game of monopoly
you go past going you get a paycheck and
if you just go around the properties
and you land on them you pay rent right
and
you can't win the game monopoly unless
you buy one green home then two green
homes and three green homes and four
then a hotel right like you have to be
an
owner in the game of monopoly the ironic
thing is that the game monopoly is a
great lesson for all of us for life
yeah you have to own assets that make
you money while you sleep
that grow while you sleep and the
challenge for most of america
is that this stuff is not taught in
school my grandmother when she started
at 30 she had nothing and she used to
literally save 50 cents a week
and put it in a coffee camp wow and at
the end of the year she took that coffee
count down to a brokerage firm
and started investing in stocks that's
what changed the entire destiny of my
family wow was that my grandmother 30
with no college education
working at gimbal's department store
milwaukee wisconsin
got tired of being poor
there's some people watching today that
are there right they're listening
they're watching this or they're
listening to this
and they're tired of being poor my
grandmother was frustrated
and she came home and said to my
grandfather on her 30th birthday
jack this is not working like and when
you're the guy and you hear that you're
like what do you mean this isn't working
and my grandfather said what's not
working and she said
we're broke we have any money and you
know to my grandmother's credit she
decided to do something about it
and so she literally brown bagged her
lunch
every day she brown bagged her lunch so
she could save that money and go invest
and the way the story turns out lewis is
my grandma thought my first book smart
women finished rich was dedicated to her
she didn't become rich overnight she
built wealth over her lifetime
yeah i always say it's decades not days
people who try to get rich quick stay
broke long
it's true like show me those banner ads
on how to get rich quick and i'll show
you
a way to stay poor forever right so my
grandmother realized like
you you invest in great american
companies and you just keep investing
and you leave it and you leave it and
you leave it and she helped me buy my
first stock at age seven at mcdonald's
wow and that was seven years old it was
like she taught me
she taught me three lessons about money
at seven that to this day
i still teach which i can share with you
what's that
so at seven we're sitting at mcdonald's
and she says you know david you can get
rich at mcdonald's
and i looked around my grandma i'm
eating my you know my cheeseburger
and my french fries and i have my apple
pie i said what are you talking about
and she's like
i'm not getting a job here she's like
see those people over there they're
working for what's called minimum wage
and i think back then minimum wage was
like a dollar
nothing and she said it's very hard to
make a living on minimum wage
she said then there's people like you
right now like all these people
are coming here and they're eating and
they're spending money that's called a
spender
and she said then there's some people
who own this place and owners get rich
and she said and i love to play monopoly
at seven that was my thing i go to my
grandmother and she played monopoly with
me
and she said i'm gonna teach you how to
play monopoly for real and she took me
home that day
she opened up the wall street journal
she circled mcd that's the symbol still
to this day for mcdonald's
and she said here's how much mcdonald's
is she put me in front of a television
screen
and said watch ticker tape she taught me
how to read that ticker tape
and she said just call out the price on
mcd that's the price of mcdonald's
and she said tomorrow i'll take you down
our broker's firm will open up an
account and you'll
you'll buy one share that stock and then
every time you go there you'll know
you're making money from yourself
wow that is a wow right and it's funny
because i'm here in l.a with you but i
just went to disneyland
two days ago with my son my son who's
nine
and disneyland did you buy disney i
bought disney that was
that was my second stop that's amazing
so like literally at nine i'm at disney
with grandma and i'm like
hey mickey are you guys public like you
know because she taught me to
think as a child like an
investor now i'm doing the same thing
with my kids now my kids don't want to
own mcdonald's they want to own
shake shack right so my son owns shake
shack
right down the street right
my younger son after disneyland is like
i want to own disney
his older brother owns disney it's
doubled he's like well i want to own
disney
my kids own amazon so you know they're
they're learning like i learned now
this stuff should be taught in school
today this is the school right like
today what we do is another way to teach
people
so but those are simple lessons i just
gave you
yeah that were passed to me and we just
did that in a matter of minutes
and rule number five the last one before
a very special bonus clip
is invest smart with tony robbins what
would you tell the startup entrepreneur
who
maybe is just getting started or maybe
still has a full-time job and it feels
like every dollar that they're making
they're just trying to
build their business at the moment they
haven't cashed out yet
should they be invested into the
business should they still be saving
some put into the market what would you
tell that person
i think you have to put something
outside your business because what's the
number one rule of investing that even
idiots understand
don't pull all your eggs in one basket
right and what did 90
of entrepreneurs do because of the
illusion of control
they go i'm gonna put all my money in my
business don't get me wrong it's still a
great place for your money and for your
time with your energy
but you got to take a piece of what you
earn and you got to bet on some other
entrepreneurs and get outside yourself
specifically
and if you look at you know somebody
like warren buffett will tell you you
know look
he said my all my wealth is a result of
a couple things some good genes
and compound interest and living in
america so
if all you do is get compound interest
on your side the game changes you take a
19 year old kid
that's got a little job and you say look
i want you it sounds like a lot but i
want to put aside 300
a month let me show you why 300 bucks a
month set aside
throw it in the market average market
return has been eight percent it's been
10 percent over 100 years but most
recent you know 30 years eight percent
so let's say you get the average return
and it compounds
that kid who starts at 19 with 300 a
month can stop at 27.
he's only done it for eight years never
put another dime in
and he's only put in 24 or 28 000
but that'll grow to 1.8 million without
putting another diamond that's the power
of compounding
28 grand 1.8 million if his best friend
starts at 27 when he quits and invests
every single year all the way to 65
and he puts in the same 300 a month he
puts in 140 grand
and at that time he's got 400 000 less
money
so it's not the amount of money it's the
amount of time
time is your greatest friend here and if
you get in the game you're gonna win and
you need to get in the game
now not wait till your business is
successful now i've got a special bonus
script from billionaire lee kashing on
how to
never squander money that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know where do you
need to take better control of your
money let me know put it down the
comments below and if you made it this
far in a video you're still here
watching and you promise you commit to
yourself that you're going to take
action we don't just watch videos here
believe nation
we do something about it give me a
hashtag believe down the comments below
if that's you
so i can celebrate with you too we've
got you tonight
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
if you want to know the 10 universal
skills that are hard to learn but will
pay
off forever check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there they are so bloody powerful it is
just beyond belief
trying to build a company and have it
succeed is like eating glass and staring
into the abyss